alien senden lichtsignale gigantisches
choralen sterben und beeindruckendes
video der nasa vom jupiter das sind nur
drei der fünf themen heute in den klicks
korallenriffe in den tiefen unserer
meere sind eines der beeindruckendsten
naturschauspiele ihre bunte farben welt
wird aber bald im nichts verschwinden
zurzeit findet die dritte weltweite
alten bleiche stadt weit mehr als die
hälfte der korallen würden der us
umweltbehörde enno ea nach schon dieses
jahr ihr farbenreiches aussehen
verlieren wenn die korallen ihre farbe
verlieren verlieren sie ihre algen diese
sind ausschlaggebend für die farbe alten
versorgen die korallen mit zucker ohne
zucker fehlt den korallen
verständlicherweise auch die energie um
sich gegen feinde also bakterien oder
ähnliches wehren zu können
durch die klimaerwärmung verändern sich
die algen und produzieren giftstoffe die
korallen müssen sie abstoßen
12.000 quadratkilometer korallenriff
fläche wäre vom sterben bedroht zitat
uns gesorgt besonders dass das phänomen
jetzt schon seit mehr als einem jahr
anhält und unsere ersten vorhersagen
zufolge auch noch bis weit ins jahr 2016
hinein andauern wird so mag hacken einer
der nkf motto natur
glaubt man den ergebnissen der
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung bz geht könnte man meinen
dass sich viele diese frage stellen vor
allem wir männer
warum soll man sich eigentlich die hände
waschen frauen waschen sich nämlich viel
öfter die hände als wehrmänner das wird
ja immer knapp behauptet aber das
scheint tatsächlich so zu sein
die landen school of hygiene tropical
medicine kam auf ein sehr unglückliches
resultat von 250.000 menschen die eine
toilette auf einer raststätte benutzt
hatten
wusch sich wenn überhaupt jeder vierte
männliche besucher seine hände
bei den frauen sah es deutlich besser
aus aber auch nicht unbedingt gut mehr
als die hälfte wusch sich nach dem
toilettengang ihre hände ernst aber ist
der ärztliche direktor des deutschen
beratungszentrums für die gene und ihm
nach würde man an einem einzigen
spülbecken
30.000 die keime pro quadratzentimeter
finden und die kommen von den händen die
gewaschen worden sind also sie sind
wirklich ziemlich heftig dreckig wie wir
männer dann noch auf die idee kommt
unsere hände nicht zu waschen das bleibt
mir ein rätsel einfach ein wenig
ekelhaft kleine info am rande rund eine
halbe minute man sich im besten fall
seine hände waschen
das nämlich ist noch ein zusätzliches
problem im jahr 2013 kamen die bzg auf
folgende zahl einer umfrage zufolge
würden gerade mal 38 prozent der
befragten 20 sekunden ihre hände waschen
zu kurz so wenig unhygienisch alien
senden lichtsignale schon vor mehr als
einem monat wurde von der yale
university über ein mysteriöses
lichtspektakel berichtet aufmerksamkeit
schenkte der entdeckung damals keiner
aber jetzt wer sich für die daten eines
der wohl bekanntesten teleskopen des
kepler teleskops interessiert kann diese
ganz einfach im internet abrufen sind
für jeden zugänglich diese möglichkeit
brachte den stern kec 846 2852 zum
vorschein er wurde von hobby astronomen
die später von der yale university
unterstützung bekam entdeckt mit dem
stern wurde etwas seriöses womöglich
lichtsignale aufgespürt seine helligkeit
fällt immer wieder und das zeitweise bis
zu 20 prozent ab zeitweise ist übrigens
ein weit greifen der begriff die
intervalle wurden zwischen 85 tagen
dauern die ursache der außergewöhnlichen
helligkeits differenzen lässt jede menge
mutmaßungen zu senden und alien signale
oder fliegt nur wieder etwas mehr
weltraumschrott durch die gegend bis
heute konnte das mysterium von kec 84 62
52 noch nicht geklärt werden von wem bzw
was stammen die lichtsignale
wie und in welchem maße quadrocopter
einfluss auf wilde tiere nehmen können
haben forscher bereits herausgefunden
sie würden die herzfrequenz zeitweise
erhöhen da haben wir ja hier wachstum
darüber berichtet wie aber sieht es mit
uns menschen aus welche rolle spielt der
sogenannte öko tourismus forscher der
universität in kalifornien haben sich
der thematik im fachmagazin trends in
ecology and evolution angenommen das
wort trends beschreibt die aktuelle
situation des ökotourismus ganz gut
immer mehr menschen gehen auf safaris
und ähnlichem und genau diese menschen
würden dafür sorgen dass die tiere immer
weniger auf ihre natürlichen feinde acht
geben würden neben der dadurch höheren
natürlichen gefahr wird auch die vom
menschlichen feinden ausgehende gefahr
größer wilderen will daran wird es
zukünftig immer leichter fallen an
wildtier heranzukommen die tiere
verlieren also nach und nach ihre
oftmals lebens entscheidende scheu nach
der ganzen news über den mars gibt es
heute mal was neues über den planeten
jupiter
die nasa hat ein beeindruckendes video
veröffentlicht auf diesem sieht man
folgendes der immer kleiner werdende
rote fleck auf dem gasplaneten die rote
fläche ist ansturm der mit einer
windgeschwindigkeit von bis zu 500
kilometern pro stunde auf dem planeten
wütet zum vergleich der hurrikan katrina
hatte zeitweise eine windgeschwindigkeit
von mehr als 250 kilometern erreicht der
nasa zufolge ist der rote fleck seit
zwei jahren enorm rasch geschrumpft
ganze 240 kilometer habe er eben
durchmesser verloren aktuell wäre er
16.000 kilometer breit vor 100 jahren
sei der sturm mehr als doppelt so breit
gewesen
grund für den rückgang experten vermuten
dass auf dem jupiter ein klimawandel im
gang ist was gerade bei uns auf der erde
so im gange ist erfahrt ihr im video
hier oben unter dem die dort gibt es das
thema tipp schaut es euch an im neuen
format pro und contra wird heiß
diskutiert diskutiert mit jetzt aber
noch eine frage an euch wer von euch
wichtig wie oft die hände und wie lang
und machte er es eben auch wirklich lang
genug könnt ihr die vorhin genannten
ergebnisse bestätigen oder seid ihr ganz
andere meinung lasst es uns in den
kommentaren wissen und bis dann bleibt
dran